last time i talked to you you had just
performed shallow by lady gaga you
impressed the judges
so much
how did this new performance feel for
you well it definitely felt
even more exciting because i got to see
the judges again
and it's just an amazing experience
[Applause]
simon hurt his back so kelly clarkson is
filling in for him i saw how excited you
got
as soon as kelly started speaking you
are incredible like you
i cannot believe your age must have been
so exciting to see her there right in
front of you
i just love her music so it was a lot of
excitement
when she said i had a great tone and
beautiful tone
i find her as an influencer for me and a
big idol for me
and a big role model as well because
she's a singer and i'm a singer
and it gives me a lot of strength
unfortunately simon couldn't be there
but i gave up some assignments
[Music]
so how did it feel performing you say by
lauren daggle
that song every time i sing it it gives
me lots of strength and faith
i also think it sends a lot of power to
people
and lots of great messages saying you
know always have faith in yourself
always believe in yourself that's what i
would like to transmit
love and peace lauren herself she
actually reposted it and she reached out
to me yes she posted it on her story and
she made
an actual post saying that i crushed the
song and that was so amazing
okay so what's next now for you when it
comes to america's got talent what are
you preparing for next
so next i am preparing a song i don't
know what song yet
i'm going to be picking but i can't wait
for you to
see it the semifinals will be in
beginning of september
and i just i can't wait to be back on
that stage to perform for
agt viewers and all of you guys